salut single j'espère que vous allez
bien on est parti pour un nouveau
décryptage de programme d'un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle aujourd'hui on
va s'intéresser à dix mesures majeures
composé par jean lassalle le candidat du
parti résistons et comme dans chaque
vidéo je vous rappelle que ce décryptage
vient en complément de l'interview du
candidat donc là en l'occurrence
l'interview de jean lassalle qui sort
dans quelques jours sur cette même
chaîne youtube et je me voulaient
découvrir du coup les interviews et
décryptage de tous les candidats et bien
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner directement
à cette chaîne youtube
alors commence comme d'habitude avec une
petite présentation jean lassalle à 66
ans il est né dans un petit village des
pyrénées dans une famille de bergers il
a démarré sa vie professionnelle en tant
que technicien agricole et à 21 ans il
est devenu l'un des plus jeunes maires
de france en devenant maire de son
village natal lourdes dur si fier il a
ensuite été élu conseiller général des
pyrénées-atlantiques en 1982 avant de
devenir député à partir de 2002 un poste
qu'il a occupé sans interruption depuis
en tant que député jean lassalle s'est
notamment fait connaître pour ses
interventions à l'assemblée nationale
souvent très remarquée en politique il
est d'abord proche de françois bayrou et
du parti centriste le modem et ce
jusqu'en 2016 date à laquelle il
réfléchit à se présenter pourquoi pas
seul à l'élection présidentielle c'est
donc ce qu'il a choisi de faire il a
terminé 7e sur onze candidats en 2017
avec 1,21 % des voix en 2022 c'est donc
sa deuxième candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
allez on passe sans plus tarder à dix
mesures de son programme la première
mesure que jean lassalle mettrait en
place à son arrivée au pouvoir concerne
la santé il souhaite en fait ouvrir 20
mille lits d'hôpitaux et recruter 100
mille infirmiers et aides soignants au
cours de son mandat concernant la santé
il souhaite aussi mettre fin aux brevets
pharmaceutiques sur les médicaments
qu'ils jugent les plus importants ce qui
permettrait en fait de rendre plus
accessibles ces médicaments car ça
permettrait d'en produire plus
facilement et en gros de ne pas réserver
la production à celui qui l'a créé
deuxième mesure comme de nombreux
candidats mais surtout des candidats à
gauche jean lassalle souhaite rétablir
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune isf
donc qui avait été supprimé en 2010 par
emmanuel macron est remplacé par l'impôt
sur la fortune immobilière lit et fit
lisf permettait de taxer les français
les plus riches ceux dont le patrimoine
en fait dépassé 1,3 million d'euros les
défis actuels fonctionnent quasiment
pareil sauf que il ne prend en compte
que le patrimoine immobilier donc les
appartements et les maisons que l'on
possède et donc ils concernent beaucoup
moins de monde la salle souhaite donc le
rétablissement de l'isf la troisième
mesure de jean lassalle elle concerne
les jeunes il souhaite élargir aux
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans l'accès au rsa
donc le revenu de solidarité active qui
est en fait un revenu en france ceux
destinés aux personnes les plus démunies
aujourd'hui ce rsa est réservé aux plus
de 25 ans et il est accessible aux moins
de 25 ans uniquement s'ils ont des
parents isolés ou alors qu'ils ont
occupé un emploi pendant au moins deux
ans cet accès au rsa pour les jeunes ce
une mesure que partage également pas mal
de candidats à gauche sous diverses
formes sachant que jean lassalle veut
aussi favoriser la gratuité des
transports publics pour les jeunes enfin
concernant les jeunes et propose
également que tous les étudiants
puissent avoir accès à un prêt de 20
mille euros de l'état à taux zéro pour
financer leurs études concrètement cela
signifie donc un près de 20000 euros
sans intérêts à verser à la banque donc
ils emprunteront 20000 euros ils auront
vingt mille euros à rembourser alors la
quatrième mesure concerne là aussi les
jeunes jean lassalle souhaite rétablir
un service national universel civils ou
militaires au choix qui concernerait en
l'occurrence toutes les filles et tous
les garçons de 18 ans et qui se
déroulerait pendant neuf mois alors
lorsque j'ai interviewé il ya quelques
jours jean lassalle mais expliqué que
dans le cadre de ce service les jeunes
seront rémunérées autour de 500 euros
par mois que l année contrat en termes
de cotisations pour la retraite et que
dans ce service est bien il sera
possible de passer aussi son permis
précise là dessus que les jeunes ne
seront donc pas obligé de faire un
service militaire j'aurais un choix
entre un service militaire et un service
civil à ce moment là dans le service
civil ils pourront travailler dans
d'autres domaines comme les hôpitaux ou
encore la reconstruction de villa 5e
mesure désormais on va parler d'économie
jean lassalle souhaite redonner à l'état
je cite l'initiative dans les secteurs
clés de l'économie pour cela il souhaite
que l'état en fait rachète un certain
nombre d'entreprises 106 les
stratégiques qui sont aujourd'hui
d'entreprises privées ça vaut pour des
domaines comme l'agriculture l'industrie
les énergies nouvelles l'automobile ou
encore l'aéronautique ça concernerait
aussi notamment edf les autoroutes de
france et toutes les entreprises en fait
liée à la défense nationale qui serait
donc nationaliser 6e mesurez vous le
verrez d'ailleurs dans mon interview
jean lassalle porte un intérêt
particulier au monde rural notamment
parce qu'il est issu d'une famille de
bergers il compte faire des campagnes
une grande cause nationale
il veut donc s'engager à 3 milliards
d'euros d'investissements pour aider la
rue réalité il propose aussi de mettre
en place un ticket paysans alors il n'a
pas précisé à qui serait distribué ce
ticket mais en tout cas il
fonctionnerait comme un ticket
restaurant sauf que il permettrait
d'acheter et bien plutôt des produits
locaux et régionaux
donc ça encouragerait les habitants à
acheter proche de chez eux jean lassalle
veut aussi revoir la distribution des
aides aux agriculteurs qui sont fixés
aujourd'hui par une politique qui
s'appelle la politique agricole commune
à l'échelle européenne jean lassalle
propose que en fait les aides
économiques aille en priorité aux
paysans qui respectent leurs terres et
leurs bêtes et n'ont donc aux grandes
exploitations selon lui qui ne vont pas
dans ce sens cette mesure s'il est élu
jean lassalle a assuré que tous les sans
abri en france auront un toit c'est une
promesse qui a également été faite par
jean luc mélenchon le candidat de la
france en soumises pour ce faire le
candidat souhaite améliorer
l'information et la prévention avec le
samu social et les maraudes encourager
aussi le bénévolat et travailler en fait
sur des solutions pérennes et long terme
pour les sans abri par exemple il
proposera des logements sociaux à bas
loyers et un accompagnement pour l'accès
aux services de santé et les différentes
démarches administratives qui peuvent
être une vraie difficulté pour les sans
abri par ailleurs pour améliorer les
conditions de vie des plus modestes jean
lassalle veut également revaloriser le
salaire minimum à 1400 euros net par
mois un peu comme jean luc mélenchon
alors qu'aujourd'hui le smic est situé à
1269 euros net par mois 8e mesure qui
elle partagée par pas mal de candidats
notamment à gauche mais aussi marine le
pen jean lassalle veut instaurer le
référendum dit hâtives les citoyennes
lerrick comme il est parfois appelée par
le mouvement des gilet jaune pour
entraîner davantage l'engagement des
citoyens dans débat public leur
permettre en fait de peser plus
directement dans les institutions et
dans les lois qui sont votées là en
l'occurrence jean lassalle souhaite que
6 700 mille personnes signent une
pétition pour qu'un référendum soit
organisé sur une question sur une mesure
alors à ce moment là et bien l'etat sera
obligé d'organiser ce référendum est de
respecter la décision issue du
référendum est temps qu'on parle de
référendum dans son programme jean
lassalle explique vouloir organiser un
référendum sur la durée du mandat du
président pour qu'il repasse
éventuellement donc à 7 ans alors
qu'aujourd'hui de la durée du mandat
d'un président est de cinq ans jean
lassalle souhaite également que le vote
blanc soit reconnue c'est à dire que on
le comptabilise dans le pourcentage
comme un vote pour un candidat et là où
c'est assez intéressant c'est que dans
le cadre d'une élection présidentielle
au second tour on peut se retrouver avec
la comptabilisation du vote blanc à
avoir et bien aucun des deux candidats
qui n'arrive à avoir plus de 50% des
voix dans ce genre de situation et bien
jean lasalle estime à ce moment là qu'il
faut organiser une nouvelle élection
avec à nouveau un premier et un second
tour et on notera au passage que cette
reconnaissance du vote blanc d'autres
candidats le souhaitent comme nicolas
dupont aignan jean luc mélenchon yannick
jadot ou encore anne hidalgo 9e mesures
concernant l'international tout comme
jean luc mélenchon nicolas dupont aignan
marine le pen ou encore eric zemmour
jean lassalle veut sortir la france de
l'otan l'otan et donc cette alliance
politique et militaire entre les états
unis et de nombreux pays européens
quand on entend beaucoup parler en ce
moment avec la guerre en ukraine par
ailleurs sur ces sujets internationaux
il souhaite donner davantage de parole à
la population est par exemple il
souhaite que le retrait des forces
françaises engagées dans un pays comme
au mali puisse être décidée soit par un
vote au parlement soit par un référendum
est donc un vote direct de la population
il souhaite enfin à renforcer la cyber
défense ou encore la recherche spatiale
sans donner cela dit beaucoup plus de
précision à les dixièmes mesure pour
terminer avant les mesures en bref jean
lassalle souhaitent investir dans les
énergies renouvelables il veut à
développer l'énergie solaire
géothermique et l'énergie de la mer
revanche sur les éoliennes il souhaite
que les mères et leurs habitants
puissent interdire toutes les
constructions d'éoliennes dans leurs
alentours s'ils le souhaitent enfin sur
l'énergie à côté de ça il veut
construire des centrales nucléaires
nouvelle génération comme emmanuel
macron vallée pécresse fabien roussel
eric zemmour ou encore marine le pen des
centrales nucléaires qui sont selon lui
plus sûr et moins cher aller comme
chaque candidat en termine avec quelques
mesures que je vais pas détailler mais
qui sont aussi portés par jour la salle
s'il est élu jean lassalle propose de
recruter six mille gendarmes et
policiers il souhaite aussi rétablir le
cumul de mandats de maire et de
parlementaires c'est à dire que un
député ou un sénateur pourrait désormais
aussi en même temps être maire d'une
ville alors que ce n'est plus autorisée
depuis 2010 est il souhaite aussi
augmenter le salaire des enseignants en
début de carrière en passant de 1500 à
2000 400 euros net par mois soit donc
900 euros de plus il souhaite aussi que
l'allocation aux adultes handicapés
soient indépendantes des revenus du
conjoint et enfin il veut mettre en
place un suivi psychologique plus
important pour les élèves victimes de
harcèlement voilà donc pour ce
décryptage du programme de jean lassalle
je voulais plus d'informations comme
d'habitude en descriptions et pour ne
pas louper l'interview de jean lassalle
qui va sortir sur cette même chaîne
youtube donc quelques jours mais aussi
d'ailleurs les décryptages les
programmes et les interviews des autres
candidats et bien n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner directement à cette chaîne
youtube vous vous aussi d'ailleurs nous
suivre sur instagram notamment on fait
des comparaisons des programmes des
différents candidats sur des mesures et
sur des sujets majeurs écoutez je crois
que je vous dis prenez soin de vous
proposons nos proches et on se dit à
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo